Hi meine Lieben!
Heute gibt's ein Brot aus der Pfanne. Das ist in der Türkei total beliebt, mit Sicherheit auch in anderen Ländern.
Wir machen nämlich Bazlama Brot und das ist erstmal nur ein Hefeteig, der ½h geht
und dann wird er nur in der Pfanne ausgebacken und alles rucki-zucki!
Also das ist ein relativ schnelles Brotrezept und es ist mega fluffig, ich liebe das!
Ich fange jetzt auch direkt an ohne groß drumherum zu quatschen.
Ich habe hier eine große Schüssel und geb da jetzt mal Mehl rein.
Ich mache das gerne so: ich nehme mir jetzt einfach 1kg, gebe da aber nicht alles rein
sondern ungefähr 800g.
Und da kommt gleich eine Mulde dazu.
So, das reicht. Da geb ich jetzt - also da mach ich jetzt eine Mulde rein mit den sauberen Händen,
gebe da schon mal einen Teil des lauwarmen Wassers dazu.
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr immer in der Infobox.
So, da gebe ich jetzt die Hälfte rein,
anschließend einen Würfel frische Hefe und etwas Zucker.
Und jetzt einmal 5min zugedeckt stehen lassen damit die Hefe arbeiten kann.
So, nach 5min konnte die Hefe richtig schön arbeiten und Wirkung zeigen
und da gebe ich jetzt alle anderen Zutaten mit dazu. Also das restliche lauwarme Wasser
einfach mit in die Schüssel und ich knete das heute alles mit den Händen.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch die Maschine nehmen, ist vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher.
Hier habe ich Salz, mit rein. Also jetzt erst, nicht vorher, das ist wichtig! Dann habe ich hier lauwarme Milch
und ein Ei. So und jetzt heißt es: kneten!
So und dann eben nach und nach erst Mehl reingeben, dann habt ihr dieses perfekte Gefühl dafür,
wann der Teig genug Mehl hat und wann so die Grenze erreicht ist
weil der muss noch richtig schön geschmeidig sein!
Und hier in der Schüssel habe ich jetzt nicht mehr ausreichend Platz,
deswegen geb ich's einmal auf die saubere Arbeitsfläche
und knete das nochmal so ungefähr 3-4min lang richtig schön durch.
So, den Teig gebe ich jetzt zurück in die Schüssel.
Vorher schön mit Mehl bestäuben, auch obendrauf ein bisschen Mehl geben damit er nicht austrocknet
und natürlich ein sauberes Küchentuch drüber geben. Und jetzt muss unsere Teigkugel 30min lang ruhen.
Also es ist ganz wichtig, dass ihr z.B. keinen Ort nehmt, wo es Durchzug gibt. Das gibt es hier bei uns
weil alles offen ist immer. Deswegen stelle ich das jetzt gleich einfach in den Backofen, der aus ist.
Ansonsten kann ich euch noch den Tipp geben: wirklich nur nach und nach Mehl dazu geben.
ich habe ungefähr 820g jetzt gebraucht-
(H: Du hast es auch da gewogen!)
Ja, ich hab nämlich extra geguckt! Ich hab auch so ein mittelgroßes Ei genommen.
Es kommt halt auch immer auf das Volumen an, ne? Also, bis gleich!
Den aufgegangenen Tag habe ich jetzt auf der bemehlten Arbeitsfläche einmal ausgebreitet
und in.. Moment! 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
In 8 gleiche-
(H: Wow! Du kannst zählen!)
In 8 gleichmäßig große Teile geteilt - wir lassen uns davon nicht irritieren!
Und erstmal habe ich die ein bisschen kleiner gemacht und dann habe ich mir gedacht:
"Nee, ich möchte lieber größere Brote haben!" Die kann man sich ja dann anschließend immer noch unterteilen.
Ihr könnt die Größe so wählen, wie ihr möchtet, ihr könnt auch 16 kleine Brote machen.
Und wir machen jetzt folgendes:
- die Hände auch am besten immer schön bemehlen -
Wir machen jetzt folgendes: einmal jede einzelne Teigkugel formen, sodass sie schön rund ist
und dann breiten wir das aus. Entweder nehmt ihr euch ein Nudelholz oder ihr nehmt einfach die Finger
und drückt das schön runter. Legt das auf die bemehlte Arbeitsfläche und dann lassen wir das nochmal
ungefähr 15-20min gehen.
So jetzt durften die bei mir nochmal 20min ruhen, 15min gehen auch in Ordnung.
Das dient einfach nur dazu, dass sich der Teig nochmal entspannt und nicht nochmal zurück zieht.
Ihr kennt das wenn man Hefeteig direkt verarbeitet, der zieht sich zurück wenn er unentspannt ist.
So und jetzt nehme ich mir hier schonmal den Teig. Gut, dass wir das mit Mehl ausgelegt haben,
so kann man das leichter anheben. Und dann-
(H: Einen hast du schon fertig gemacht!)
Genau, einen habe ich schon fertig gemacht. So und jetzt einmal in die heiße Pfanne geben.
Also was heißt heiß, ich hab jetzt hier -
Ich hatte anfangs Stufe 8 von 9, bin auf 6 runter, bin dann auf 5 runter.
Da müsst ihr einfach so das Gefühl dafür kriegen. Nicht zu heiß weil es soll ja richtig innen auch gar werden
und außen nicht zu dunkel. Ihr kriegt also auf jeden Fall ein Gefühl dafür nach dem ersten.
Jedes Bazlama Brot wird dann ungefähr 2 ½ - 3min von jeder Seite ausgebacken. Ganz wichtig: Ohne Fett!
Also wirklich nur in der beschichteten Pfanne. Und verlasst euch jetzt auch nicht auf exakt diese Angabe
weil jeder Herd heizt anders, ihr habt vielleicht eine andere Hitze.
Ihr müsst einfach echt so ein Gefühl dafür entwickeln-
(H: Jede Pfanne ist anders!)
Jeder Pfanne ist anders, genau. So, jetzt habe ich beide Seiten
direkt nach dem Ausbacken mit Butter bestrichen.
Das braucht ihr auch, das ist ganz wichtig! Und jetzt habe ich noch einen Top Tipp für euch:
Versucht doch mal Butter Ghee, das ist reines Butterschmalz und das ist soo lecker!
Ich geb' da jetzt auf jeden Fall nochmal auf ein paar Bazlamas hier dieses Butter Ghee drauf, einfach so.
Und dann nehme ich jetzt einen Pinsel und verteile das auch von beiden Seiten.
Das hat echt so einen ganz anderen Eigengeschmack. Müsst ihr einfach mal probieren!
(H: Boah das sieht auch schon so lecker aus Kiki!)
Das ist auch mega lecker und total soft!
Also wenn ihr jetzt auch Lust habt auf dieses mega softe Bazlama Brot, dann unbedingt  hier unten
in die Videobeschreibung schauen, da schreibe ich euch ganz genau die Mengenangaben hin.
Ansonsten meinen Kanal unbedingt ein kostenloses Abo da lassen! Und wenn ihr möchtet,
mache ich mehr Brotrezepte, auch mehr in die orientalische, vielleicht auch in die indische Schiene!
Wir wollten ja auch mal Naan Brot, dieses.. oder Ballon Brot wollte ich gerne machen!
(H: Fli!)
Oder Fli, albanisch!
Also schreibt mir eure Wünsche hier in die Kommentare, da richte ich mich sehr gerne nach!
Und dann sehen wir uns bei meinem nächsten Rezept und ich back hier fleißig weiter aus!
Tschüss!
(H: Vielleicht zur aktuellen Lage Brot ohne Hefe!)
Oh ja, Brot ohne Hefe ist auch eine gute Idee!
Ich habe mich jetzt leicht erschrocken aber ok! Gute Idee auf jeden Fall!
Also bis dann, Tschüss!